bonjour bienvenue à 7 entre éditions dc
espace autochtone en direct je m'appelle
l'admr yvon encore aujourd'hui toute une
table et autour de moi bonjour à tous
bonjour alors aujourd'hui on va parler
d'emploi parce qu'il ya un événement qui
approche cette semaine le 8 novembre à
montréal et c'est le salon de l'emploi
autochtone de montréal le salon mamou
pour en parler de leurs cendres et
bonjour dans l'aurès cauet beaux jours
et puis vous avez amené evelyn evelyn -
bord de l'eau evelyne qui travaillait
également au centre de services urbains
de montréal mais qui est aussi une
chercheuse d'emploi c'est bien ça oui
j'ai des chercheuses d'un poids donc
c'est réglé maintenant pour vous vous
avez trouvé un emploi oui en tant
qu'agente projet est-ce que c'est
l'emploi que vous vouliez selon les
selon le bac il est diplômé ce que vous
alliez ses connexes ses connexes ok
alors on va en parler un petit peu plus
en profondeur
d'abord on va s'intéresser à ce salon de
l'emploi ça a lieu le 8 novembre
ça fait en fait plusieurs années que ça
existe c'est pas nouveau la non c'est
sur le salon importe octobre à montréal
tu vaux rien justement le 8 novembre
jeudi prochain oui se nomme mamour mamou
veut dire ce mot en i know we qui veut
dire ensemble vous saviez chat qui veut
dire ensemble oui c'est à dire que parce
qu on est un groupe d'organisations
autochtones jusqu'à demain qui se nomme
le cercle des premières masses le cercle
de l'éducation que l'employabilité du
réseau à pied par lequel on se rencontre
une fois par mois pour travailler
ensemble pour organiser l'événement
d'accord donc il a lieu une fois par
année est ce qu'il est très populaire il
est courue par les autochtones
oui de plus en plus c'est un cas même un
événement quand même assez reconnu p2
réputé il en est qui est de plus en plus
connus de
même dire des organisations autochtones
qui s'applique beaucoup
il ya des communautés autochtones qui
viennent participer également d'accord
donc ce ne sont pas que des
organisations installé à montréal ça
vient de partout
oui c'est ok alors par exemple un
exemple quel genre d'organisation peut
être la balle à cette année on retrouve
on va avoir 48 exposants à c'est
beaucoup et donc qui sont composées de 2
soit des employeurs des intervenants
autochtone de différentes organismes
autochtones hameau rien oui qui oeuvrent
dans le domaine de l'emploi la formation
l'éducation
ok également il va voir aussi des
centres de formation qui vont être
inclus tout ça pour rassembler c'est
tout ce monde là pour aider les
autochtones à faciliter leur intégration
aux points wii et vinay ce que vous êtes
passé par le salon de l'emploi est ce
que c'est comme ça que vous vous êtes
retrouvé au centre de services urbains
n'ont rien jamais que c'est la première
fois que vous que vous lui en fait la
première fois que quoi que vous avez
participé ou que vous allez participer
que je vais participer en plus de
travailler dans l'organisation oui ok
jamais vous n'aviez venu rencontrer des
réseaux regagné sous venus voir ce que
le salon au frais c'est vraiment arrivé
non ce n'était pas arrivé auparavant
d'accord charme ou est ce que vous êtes
des jaloux salon de l'emploi
oui j'ai déjà été en fait j'avais été
invité à venir partager mon expérience
quand j'étais
comment comme ça comment on peut se
retrouver afin que jeunes quinconque est
une communauté de combien s'installe à
montréal à crois qu'on est confronté et
puis j'avais été invité à venir partager
cette expérience lors d'un salon de
quelques âmes d'accord parce que c'est
ça c'est l'occasion aussi de faire du
réseautage là de rencontrer des gens
comme charles qui ont une nouvelle
expérience et d'autres personnes ça fait
c'est ça le but l'objectif vraiment de
ma bourse est vraiment rassembler toutes
les intervenants les employeurs puissent
créer un partenariat réel avec les
employeurs
les centres de formation tout le pays
faire connaître aussi aux jeunes soient
des chercheurs d'emploi oui ceux qui
veulent retourner aux études
la gare d'aulnay les critères
d'admissibilité sombre des trois grains
oui aux mains des critères d'embauché
pour des employeurs alors quand on est à
montréal et qu'on est autochtone
quels sont les secteurs d'emploi dans
lesquels on a le plus d'accès je vous
c'est très difficile de généraliser
parce qu'il faut dire que la clientèle
autochtone mémorial est très diversifiée
donc ils proviennent de différentes
nations de diverses communautés
autochtones à travers le canada
on est donc notre approche est vraiment
l' approche client donc les domaines
recherché par les autochtones sont
également très diversifié donc on essaie
de varier pièce que des domaines qui
sont plus lents général qui sont plus
prisées louis vers lequel ils ont plus
tendance à se trouver
je dirais que juste le lieu de travail
en relation died à oui tout ça parce que
on reconnaît qu' un des obstacles que la
clientèle or actuellement je veux dire
les obstacles peuvent varier
c'est à dire
et autant les obstacles au niveau à
sociale personnelle économique
académique et donc on fait affaire avec
beaucoup de travail ensemble avec des
intervenants autochtones qui sont
localisés à montréal les organismes
autochtones et les gens un autre
obstacle dont j'aimerais parler
également c'est surtout s'il a la langue
ouais majoritairement je dirais que les
autochtones je dirais qu'ils sont quand
même bilingues dont ils parlent leur
langue maternelle est une des deux
langues officielles oui il ya nos mecs
sont trilingues grille par contre comme
on sait à montréal bell le bilinguisme
est un critère très en demande
c'est-à-dire la l'incontournable ont
fait ça de plus en plus oui donc un
moteur et un doigt et trilingue qui lui
qui parle la langue bilingue français
lorsqu on encourage souvent c'est que on
encourage les employeurs à offrir des
cordes allende à nouveau lorsqu'il
recrutons notre souhait c'est parce que
des fois c'est juste ça peut être juste
une question de langue de ce que
lorsqu'il refuse de pau s'arrêter à ça
parce que la personne peut avoir un
noeud un niveau de base un exemple et
puis
voici lui manque seulement la langue et
ça serait cool et donner la chambre
exact evelyne vous quels sont les plus
grands obstacles que vous avez eu à
surmonter jusqu'à présent en tant que
chercheuse d'emploi en tant que
chercheuse que lorsque je suis sorti
deux plus récents domaine que j'ai
étudié technologie d'électronique donc
jamais que l'on m'a informé qu'il y
avait plusieurs possibilités d'emploi là
puis sow va donc on m'a informé aussi
que tu es j'allège de salles étaient
très difficiles à décrocher un emploi
pourquoi pourquoi salle est difficile
c'était quoi les obstacles de vouloir
chercher un emploi dans ce domaine la
difficulté d'apprentissage pays étaient
souvent mal informés aussi que c'était
centré sur la performance et la
concurrence des entreprises
oui pas facile non au niveau des langues
vous parlez combien de langues
je parle je parle deux langues l'anglais
et le français
d'accord donc au moins vous êtes capable
d'entrer dans n'importe quelle
entreprise avec nouveau de langues
oui mais c'est pour autant ce n'est pas
facile non alors en fait le fait de
participer cette année au salon de
l'emploi qu'est ce que vous voulez aller
y chercher en fait c'est ça je travaille
dans l'organisation en tant qu'agent
premier oui mais sinon pour vous est ce
que vous avez envie de rencontrer de
futurs employeurs est ce que vous voulez
avoir des ressources particulières ça
m'a traversé l'esprit mais pour
l'instant vous allez voir vous allez
voir ce qu est ce que vous demande qui
vous intéresseront vous
les castings dans cette période étant
donné que ces contractuels de saisir l
opportunité nu oui bien sûr oui oui
alors vous charles vous êtes dans le
domaine artistique neige molle et des
chercheurs d'emploi donc chez les
artistes et y en a beaucoup mais il ya
des programmes qui leur sont offerts des
programmes de formation artistique entre
eux
oui mais tout à fait il ya des
programmes qui sont qui sont implantés
qui ont été implantées au cours des
années a eu un programme avec ondine hoc
en collaboration avec l'école nationale
en 2004 a duré quelques années ça c'est
en 2005 qu'il national dtn les
conditionnalités entre exactement
et puis en fait c'était pour favoriser
puis favoriser les artistes autochtones
de montrer qu'elle présente comédie
autochtone ou 6 de leur donner du
matériel de formation qu'ils soient
qu'ils soient aussi formé par des gens
d'instituts reconnu des instituts privés
oui
donc c'est ce que je trouvais super
intéressant aussi
il ya d'autres joueurs aussi de deux
formations comme le musée canadien de
l'histoire il offre un programme de
formation à muséologie pour les
premières nations
donc ça peut être le fun aussi quelqu'un
qui veut travailler avec les vestiges de
nos enceintes ou les avec les
expositions des premières nations des
choses comme ça donc ça peut être très
enrichissant présentement il ya eu il ya
eu un appel de candidatures au côté
anglophone et francophone où c'est
l'école nationale de théâtre chercher en
mars 2010 et ont cherché des artistes
oui j'ai eu l'occasion de leur parler
ils ont de la difficulté à y auront eu
de la difficulté à recruter des gens et
moi que moi j'ai pas postuler parce que
c'était le côté anglophone qui est en
premier lieu de ça mais bloqué jeudi
matin dans l'année prochaine en 2010
neuf par là mais je pense que ça a été
avancé devancé je sais pas trop puis
voilà fait que c'est comme pisser soleil
laugnac il est en résidence d'artiste
pour deux années soyez à l'honneur un
cérémonial oui une publicité ça permet
d'avoir un accompagnement d'avoir de
pouvoir se développer ce super forme
est ce cela se se concentrer sur si
plein de l'élaborer donc je quitte à
mentir des résidences d'artistes de deux
mois mais c'est pour te donner une place
de création on veut de l'accompagnement
on veut avoir la formation c'est moi
j'ai utilisé en théâtre à l'uqac qui le
bac et indiscipline a donc c'est quelque
chose de plus concentré sur la sur la
création que sur la technique et du
campo chicoutimi hh inexactement et puis
mais alors quels sont les besoins des
artistes autochtones
est-ce qu' on a des besoins et oui y ait
beaucoup de besoins mais moi je dirais
bâton pour les communautés pour les
communautés je crois qu'ils avaient
besoin de deux centres d'artistes
davantage davantage de centres de
création web pour qu'on puisse pour
qu'on puisse faire des formations justin
haché qui chez qu'il y ait plusieurs
endroits chics hamas teillage c'est un
endroit comme ça pour qu'on puisse créer
qu'on peut s'échanger qu'on puisse avoir
un endroit pour peindre quelque chose
sur le capot donc c'est des choses comme
ça et avoir plus fait plus facilement
aux accès aux programmes d'être
financière comme reconnaît il ya eu qui
est sorti dernièrement suis pas un
programme ça nous donne la possibilité
de pouvoir créer des choses
extraordinaires d'avoir un enveloppe qui
nous est consacré pour qu'on puisse
élaborer où il grandit dans ce domaine
oui alors je vous interromps madame
andrée pour les artistes autochtones est
ce que au salon il ya il ya des
ressources pour ces gens là c'est sûr
qu'il ya beaucoup de étant donné qu'elle
sarc quand même 46 exposants dans
différents domaines
ça permet de faire un réseautage de
faire connaître vos compétences vous et
puis justement développer des liens avec
des personnes aux six ans dans le milieu
des arts de la culture parce qu'il ya
souvent on fait ce qu'on veut créer
aussi c'est vraiment un sens à la
communauté un appartenance à la
communauté comme un exemple un char
l'état où les actions dans le domaine de
la rue les artistes oui bâtisse en ayant
un en développant des liens avec un
d'autres autochtones me fait connaître
dans l'autre tout à l'heure et à cliff
cardinal donc c'était laissant de très
intéressant de découvrir des gens de
voir qu'est-ce qu'il faut aussi miser le
réseautage dans le domaine des arts le
résultat c'est la clé du bilan en
contact avec les gens avec qui on l'a
déjà travaillé qu'elle se fait toujours
à être alimentée par stadler danic leur
dis que je suis là je suis exactement
voilà ce que j'ai à vous offrir c'est de
faire connaître nos forces nos
compétences et c'est ça qui est
nécessaire des objectifs parce que
souvent elle a un des obstacles cesser
les des autochtones souvent on met
connaissent très peu mais quand ils ont
une méconnaissance sur les techniques
d'entrevue
comment se vendre comment approcher les
employeurs
bahia qui réclament vite et parfois la
barre assassin l'auriculaire - ouais et
plus par rapport aux artistes mais je
sais que nos aussi les gens qui veulent
retourner aux études sont dans le
domaine des arts ou la formation ou quel
que soit le domaine
on peut également souhaité offrir un
soutien financier pour une personne qui
veulent retourner aux études soient leur
donner une allocation de formation ou
aider couvrir des frais les sensations
dans quelques métiers que ce soit là
donc autant pour les artistes du pour un
autre corps de métier c'est simple donc
si moi si je voudrais faire du ddl
d'appoint en diction l'exemple je
pourrais avoir demandé une rappeler la
formule a demandé une aide par rapport
aux salles ont annoncé les organisateurs
très intéressant même sont en emploi qui
veut se perfectionner pour améliorer
leurs compétences dans leur domaine il
ya des services sur des programmes
financière pour aider ces personnes
c'est intéressant parce que je vois
revenir avec ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure avec la la langue c'est l'heure
pour la réalité dans le match
ok ça c'est ma réalité amoureux j'arrive
à montréal on demande d'être bilingue je
parle très peu anglais je dirais je
baragouine c'est bon et puis mettez pas
accès aux programmes anglophones qui est
qui qui sont parfois beaucoup plus
élaboré beaucoup plus complet
dans l'ouest canadien beaucoup de
développements au niveau des avants et
vous aurez des premières nations au
niveau de la de faire briller la route
akon et beaucoup beaucoup de
développement hockey au québec ça ça
commence comme ça commençait pas mais
c'est plus restreint pour ceux qui
restent et dont il se sentait donc on
sort on vient à montréal et c'est
justement rien en fait c'est juste ça
c'est de là que nous sommes consacrées
difficile et puis le jeune qui a du
talent puis qui veut quitter la
communauté pour aller étudier c'est pas
facile pour ce jeune l'audit et la
communauté aller à montréal s'installer
là pour aller faire son rêve réalisé son
rêve c'est pas facile ça c'est une
adaptation adaptation ou rapprochés
pendant que les services dans les
communautés où l anc et des choses comme
ça mais vous me disiez il ya votre
organisme il existe dans 83 autres
régions au québec c'est cela comme ça
des ressources humaines des premières
nations du québec consiste à notre
mission d'un fossé de gérer et d'offrir
les services d'emploi et d'information
et on a 30 au point de services à
travers le québec dont dans des
communautés
oui et 400 de services urbains dont
québec donald à montréal et sept-îles et
c'est bien connu par les autochtones ils
le savent que ça existe qu'ils ont ces
ressources là oui généralement oui je
veux dire c'est sûr que on fait beaucoup
de bouche à oreille excédé connu ccc
très connu dans le monde est active dans
les milieux urbains
c'est un milieu urbain pataquès le lui
qui reste dans une communauté comme
hamas et oui achoui qui quittent moins
un contact avec ce qu'il peut être qu'il
le voit moins souvent mais sa part sur
les réseaux sociaux on entend parler
partager par les organes sd compte c'est
donc on sait trés s'est très rapidement
mais oui absolument
absolument alors chalon on va terminer
on parlait des besoins des artistes
autochtones maintenant on pourrait
parler aussi des solutions pour
favoriser le développement artistique là
chez les premières nations
c'est ce que faisais tu as là c'est
d'implanter je pense un peu des
programmes dans les communautés je pense
qu'on pourrait faire des choses avec les
conseils de bande
pour essayer de développer ccsc ses
talents dans les communautés à se lier
parce que je pense que quelque chose il
ya quelque chose à sa pas sortir des
communautés mais à aller chercher pour
le faire pour faire briller nos
communautés justement parce qu'il ya des
petits bijoux qui ne sortiront kiki qui
vont s'arrêter à nous et à sauter puis
ils ont peu plus loin effectivement ce
que je veux c'est peut-être essayer de
leur donner une perche pour qu'on puisse
essayer de 2 je parle pour la nouvelle
génération les artistes qui s'en vient
nous on est happé naturel on sait
maintenant c'est quoi qu'il faut faire
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire aussi pour
nous nos plus jeunes artistes
ce qui est intéressant aussi vrai et
puis exemple je l'écris moment il y à
des programmes d'art à l'école pour le
secondaire il y avait des artistes pour
pour
les accompagner dans leur démarche
académique et tout ça donc il ya
vraiment cessé commence par habitude ça
dépasse a dépassé les artistes qui sont
invités tous dépendants s'apprête en
peinture et en forme et artistes donc
c'est quand même intéressant c'est quand
même des problèmes qui sont fans à être
intégrés dans des communautés parce que
ce que je pense aussi par rapport avec
les artistes ont besoin c'est un un
portfolio nouvelle savent pas comment le
développer pour aller justement cherché
de l'aide nécessaire
c'est dispendieux de ses shooting photo
pour un mannequin glace et se dispersent
à toute chasse à courre
[Musique]
on peut toujours des référés les
individus qui ont des besoins
spécifiques
un des programmes existants mais adore
par exemple si je travaille je sais pas
en construction je suis autochtone je
travaille en construction est ce que je
vais pouvoir aussi trouvé au salon
autochtone oui des gens pour m'aider
pour me conseiller pour me guider
c'est ça juste pour n'en nommer
quelques-uns justement et la commission
de la construction du québec qui vont
être présents il ya un patrimoine canada
qui vont être présents peut-être que
vous pourrez vous pouvez leur demander
si au niveau des arts la culture et la
langue
1 puis tout le développement culturel
autochtone parce que je trouve c'est un
point très intéressant parce que moi je
me dis toujours un individu qui veut se
cherchent un emploi
il faut qu'ils se connaissent bien il
faut qu'ils connaissent bien son origine
culturel autochtone également donc
toutes ces aspects là sont importantes à
être mis en place à être développé pour
justement que les individus puissent
bien se développer dans son cheminement
professionnel ou académique
ce sont des aspects aussi qu'on essaie
de développer avec les employeurs au
sein des organismes autochtones corps
parce que on veut aussi sensibiliser les
uns les employeurs décarie des
caractéristiques comme donne lors des
règles et des recrutements pour
justement faciliter l'embauché temps
venu
et viser les préjugés oui c'est ça ça se
brise plus se combattre le racisme la
discrimination à l'emploi
on a aussi créé des outils pour les
employeurs qui vont être mis qui vont
être lancés qui va distribuer aux
employeurs de mamou justement pour leur
donner des trucs comme en embaucher les
autochtones ou à l'ailé recruté comme un
désir qui ne sont pas autochtone donc
qui ont besoin de savoir donc heroes on
voit on les sensibilise ou et sont
toujours très intéressés à venir
justement pour connaître aussi la
situation
oui et la réalité autochtone absolument
alors là je vais demander à la
journaliste émilie dubreuil de se
joindre à nous bonjour bonjour bonjour
on va changer de sujet il n'est pas le
moment même ouais l'emploi l'emploi
quand même n a pas que ceux là dedans
parce que quand on souffre du diabète
on ne veut pas travailler ou enfin c'est
beaucoup plus difficile selon les
handicaps qui vont venir avec si on a
été amputé à cause du diabète se trouver
un emploi après c'est pas évident mais
ça ça nous amène emilie à un reportage
que vous avez fait vous êtes allé à
malioténam et ce reportage à londres oui
oui monteront entre d'accord on va en
parler mais si vous avez fait le
reportage c'est que vous vouliez aller
voir sur le terrain la réalité suite à
une étude du centre de gouvernance de
l'information
pardon des premières nations du canada
ils ont sorti une étude sur la
prévalence du diabète dans les
communautés ce qui est enlevée c'est que
cet été j'ai une connaissance que
j'avais pas vu depuis de nombreuses
années qui me téléphonent me dit que mon
frère est un travailleur de la santé
on dirai pas ce qui fait puis où il est
allé et il est très ému et très inquiet
de ce qui l'a constaté dans une
communauté autochtone en régions
éloignées très loin
d'accord alors juste un coup et cette
connaissance m'a dit il veut parlant
journalistes absolument il
veut qu'on parle de ce sujet là un sujet
j'imagine que vous connaissez trenet et
donc ce travailleur là me contacter il
est en larmes et il me dit je suis très
très inquiet ouais je n'ai jamais vu
autant de gens atteints par cette
maladie là et 10 faut absolument que les
médias en parlent
il faut que ce soit connue à l'extérieur
des communautés parce que c'est une
réalité que les communautés vous
connaissez super bien mais titi qui
pensent qu'ils passent quasiment
inaperçues s'est établi à g avait tête
c'est bon faut que je fasse attention il
ya une sorte de fatalisme dans les
communautés on se dit mais mon oncle m'a
grand mal comme ça je vais la voir à ses
poches une éthique dans les diamètres
bien comprend met donc à partir de cette
conversation le kimono massaise oui oui
et a attiré mon attention je me suis dit
bon je vais commencer à m'intéresser
donc j'ai lu certaines études et avoir
accès à des chiffres est extrêmement
difficile parce que c'est un sujet tabou
et il est dans les organismes dans les
ministères on me disait que y'en a
combien mettons c'est quoi le plat pire
le pire taux 2020 oui oui nous sommes
noirs stigmatise une communauté où le
moins pays oui on disait mais c'est pas
de leur faute
non non c'est pas ça la question c'est
combien j'ai dit une crise de santé
publique
et c'est ça qu'il faut que les gens
comprennent à l'extérieur des
communautés c'est que c'est une
véritable crise de santé publique
et quand on parle de santé publique chez
les autochtones on parle souvent des
problèmes de suicides par exemple de
toxicomanie mais ça et c'est pour ça que
j'ai intitulé mon dossier l'ennemi
silencieux des communautés autochtones
c'est que quand on regarde les chiffres
c'est affolant c'est à dire que les
lignes d'eau de prévalence dans les
communautés autochtones
c'est vrai au québec c'est vrai au
canada mais c'est vrai aussi aux états
unis
et c'est vrai en indonésie ou en
australie chez tous les peuples
autochtones du monde
on a des taux de prévalence du diabète
de 2 à 3 fois voire quatre fois plus
élevé selon les communautés des
mathématiques il ya petit chiffre
magique mais c'était mathématiques très
variable selon les zones d'isolement des
communautés et cela aussi l'isolément
culturel alors plus les communautés sont
à forte identité culturelle
plus on va avoir une résistance est ce
que je suis ce que j'ai un peu découvert
en faisant du terrain en une résistance
à ce qui est associé à skis blanc alors
ironiquement on en oeuvre dans les
années 40 dans les années 50 les gens
qui avaient des sous dans les
communautés oui le curé le président de
la compagnie minière y manger quoi y
manger des frites des cheeseburgers des
tares de gâteaux les autochtones à côté
était pauvre mais oui reposera et puis
se disait regardez et c'est ce symbole
de la réussite
oui j'oubliais râteau et ironiquement
par un système de transfert culture et
oui oui c'est entrer dans la norme
culturelle est aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'autochtones qui disent mais c'est la
façon autochtone de manger modèle m'a
alors c'était comment revirement
sociologie oui et aussi les autochtones
puis en fait je me sens un peu mal à
l'aise de parler de vie parce que vous
pourriez tous parler de ça 10 on est un
peu tanné de se faire traiter comme des
patients dans un hôpital
alors quand le bon médecin gentil harry
dans une communauté pizza on mange du
brocoli et joggi hinske mail soit
tranquille il ya neuf ans il ya beaucoup
de dimension mais vous
lien avec l'emploi ce qui est très très
clair et ça ressort dans toutes les
communautés à travers le monde sait que
plus une communauté est riche donc plus
les gens travaillent n'y est plus une
communauté et bien est en santé jallet
2000 motards ce we noyade et donc plus
les niveaux d'éducation sont élevées
moyen de dire oui c'est vraiment une
occasion bien avec ça aussi le docteur
stanley molloy qui vous avait parlé le
mentionne aussi l'éducation mais il ya
beaucoup d'hommes coin lien avec tous
les maux qui affectent certaines
communautés autochtones
donc si ça l'est vraiment il ya beaucoup
beaucoup d'études qui tente à démontrer
aussi que c'est une maladie qui
résultent de l'exclusion et d'un
changement de racisme dans la mesure où
les autochtones ont peu tendance non
plus à consulter tant que ça mais sont
ils aussi bien desservi par nos systèmes
de santé
autrement dit en posant la question du
diabète
on veut beaucoup plus loin dans des
questions fondamentales telles que le
colonialisme le mal de villes ou échange
le juge de la mise en réserve
ça fait ça fait pas si longtemps on
parle centaines d'années l'alimentation
a changé complètement complètement pts 6
en fait c'est ce qu'ils ont dit y a
pendant longtemps ne pensez que c'est
génétique
on avait une espèce de thèse qui avait
un peu de bon sens qui lisait les
autochtones ont été nomades ils ont été
confrontés à des famines donc
génétiquement ils ont un jeune économe
qui fait en sorte qu'ils emmagasinent
j'ai tout à fait faux y'avait pas de
diabète etc ce qui causerait dans la
sédentarité
oui l'embonpoint et le diabète qui
vivait à crédit
sauf que le constat est le constat est
alarmant
les chiffres là c'est que dans en ce
moment les tous se sont stabilisés à peu
près autour de 20% de kiel prévalence du
diabète ou québec dans la population
générale pour vous donner une idée la
csu 6,9 pour cent des gens si on exclut
les enfants de moins de 12
d'accord nous quel point alors dans
certaines communautés au québec là on va
atteindre 7 personnes sur 10 décembre la
rencontre ça vous donne une idée
oui mais ce qui se passait là c'est ce
qui est le plus affolant c'est d'une
part les autochtones
selon les statistiques ons de deux à
trois fois plus de chances de développer
des complications liées au diabète
ce ça veut dire ses idées ça veut dire
amputation oui ça vous sur
l'insuffisance rénale oui c'est des
problèmes extrêmement bien pour ce
qu'ils ne sont pas suivies ou parce que
y aura de la maladie une résistance au
suivi beaucoup d'autochtones pense que
cette arrivée va nous expliquer ce qu'il
m'a dit ça doit obligatoirement faire
mal oui et donc ça fait pas mal et le
diabète pendant longtemps peut être
asymptomatique ça fait comment l'on veut
on va pas consulté et elle a résisté
il ya beaucoup d'études aussi qui dément
qu'un certain mal de vivre si j'ai pas
envie si je peux pas me projeter dans
l'avenir
oui pourquoi je prendrais un chance
le sait ce qui nous attend ce qui est
inquiétant
oui par ailleurs c'est les taux
d'obésité ne cesse d'augmenter dans les
communautés autochtones au québec et au
canada
je vous donne un chiffre entre 2 et 11
ans l'âge de 2 et 11 en un an avant sur
deux dans les communautés autochtones
est obèse
aux baisses poids surpoids au bate
obèses et la proportion d'adolescents
qui souffrent d'obésité un doublé dans
les derniers dix ans alors si on regarde
dans l'avenir c'est extrêmement
inquiétant dans un pays où la moitié en
ce moment la courbe démographique dans
les communautés autochtones les jeunes
la moitié de la population a moins de 30
ans et l'âge fatidique pour le diabète
ses 40 ans alors si on regarde dans
l'avenir on se projette dans l'avenir
ces enfants les adolescents devront
devenir des adultes et la chance il
développe le diabète extrêmes tous les
problèmes qui viennent avec mathis vu
qu'ils couvraient le nord du canada donc
que ce soit le nunavik le nunavut
la réalité elle est très grande là où
c'est différent c'est ça mais seulement
si je le suis demandé quel était l'état
des vieux chais justement les inuit du
nunavik puis on se rend compte que les
dernières données sur la question parle
justement la difficulté de trouver les
les données qui commence peut-être à
bout mais chez les nounous et justement
il ya un état des lieux qui a été fait
en 2004
donc là le dernier portrait qui a été
brossé de l'état de santé des inuits ont
avec roman pas bien trop longtemps il
doit nous sont plus jeunes et tous égaux
sortie exacte j'ai mis la main dessus si
vous voulez je veux pas encore public
mais bon je sais dans la réponse de
rater le parrain mais complètement
différent chez les inuit
néanmoins le taux de diabète augmenté
mais c'est pas du tout la même ampleur
la maladie ne les aurait pas de la même
façon le pour des questions de génétique
a alors jeune suppose une bien justin
boyes on y verra bien si aujourd'hui
mais aussi d'alimentation c'est à dire
que ce nous attend beaucoup garder la
façon de s'alimenter
c'est drôle c'est drôle
ma copine me disais que j'y goût de
manger de la viande de bourthes
notamment rien trouver de la viande de
beauté quand états unis zone communauté
était sous ma vie mais c'était quand
même
hillman quelles sont leurs 50 de ses
besoins
mais chez les enfants chez un des sens
où si chez les new world les proportion
augmente avec les chiffres augmentent
sont beaucoup moins oui oui oui j'ai
chez les premières nations ou au sud
d'un certain parallèle mais il s'attend
à augmenter mais ça augmente aussi dans
les populations défavorisées des frères
s'est brisée frère que je vous écoute
parler mais en même temps un ski est
tabou c'est justement à cause d'un grand
manque d'information ou à de
sensibilisation auprès de la clientèle
ciblée des communautés les premières
aussi des fois il faut vulgariser
l'information on allait changer les gens
et non pas juste de distribuer des
documents aux faut faire des activités
avec dans sa roue
on ne peut pas passer à la question à
côté la question de mon du coût de la
vie c'est tout ça c'est sûr que
l'économie c'est très dispendieux mais
en même temps mais en même temps cette
fois-ci culte faisons l'exercice
beaucoup de communautés qui sont à
proximité de grands centres quelqu'un
qui est à maliotenam peut aller
facilement satire ou et chercher mais va
rester dans la communauté peut pas avoir
ce réflexe là c'est pas systématiquement
j'ai pas un accès et le gouvernement
fédéral est très conscient du problème
et des coûts associés aux problèmes
alors elles ont aussi dit oui c'est
s'investit à peu près 50 millions par
année dans les communautés excluant la
colombie-britannique en prévention et
samassa delà de l'argent investi mais le
délai variant de mention manifestement
ça marche pas non pourquoi ça marche pas
ou est ce que ça bloque layoule
le noeud du problème pour elle chante
hamas tant qu'il faut aller demander aux
individus qui sont qui ont ce problème
alors là pour leur demander des
solutions direction ce que je pouvais
utiliser parce que moi je suis témoin
j'analyse bowie mais hier programme qui
fonctionne et il est géré par une
communauté c'est à dire que les mots
works en 95 se sont rendus compte que il
y avait le double de prévalence du
diabète dans leur communauté et le
problème vient de la communauté est géré
par la communauté avec l'argent de la
communauté
les années sont très investi là-dedans
les écoles joyeuse investi là-dedans et
donc c'est quelque chose qui vient de
messages et les choses de l'extérieur je
dirai et je suis pas une experte mais je
dirais que si on veut essayer de
comprendre le départ d'être pourquoi ça
ne marche pas tant une multitude de
facteurs il ya celle là mais il ya aussi
si un individu qui est un peu déprimé va
aller chercher un paquet de biscuits
pour manger ses émotions et manger ses
émotions
maintenant voilà on m'a dit on peut
appeler ça aux premières nations des
nations qui sont primés déprimé qui ont
certains problèmes ont tendance à manger
plus et là on a pu faire tous les
programmes qu'on veut en fait c'est un
symptôme de quelque chose mais il faut
s'attaquer au fond du problème
alors pour terminer mathis on va
terminer avec vous parce que vous
parliez de l'étude qui a été fait au
nunavik en 2004 mais il va y avoir de
nouvelles données c'est sortir la suède
en fait c'est ce que je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez en 2000 l'été 2010 est une
quarantaine d'experts et de chercheurs
et qui se sont rendus à bord de l'arène
la moyenne brise glace de la garde
côtière canadienne qui a parcouru dans
les quatorze communautés de la baie
james à la baie d'ungava pour justement
re brosser un portrait de la situation
est plus actuelle savoir si elle aussi
en matière de diabète d'obésité surpoids
gtrra puis il ya à peu près deux mille
2000 résidants qui ont été justement
tester donc les données sont amenés la
date de l'étude et on ignore encore
quand est-ce que ça va être rendus
publics officiellement mais les données
l'échantillonnage est prêt ça devrait ça
devrait être rendu public dans les
prochains épisodes on va faire un autre
reportage est vraiment dans le grand
nord alors votre reportage vous avez
fait un reportage web donc un long texte
mais il ya également le reportage qui
disent tous ça c'est toujours disponible
sur le site de radio canada seulement
ah ben c'est lent puis faut absolument
aller de pair
absolument et puis on va terminer avec
le salon de l'emploi alors ça se passe
où et quand ça se passe jeudi prochain
le 8 novembre au salon urbain de la
place des arts à montréal on évite tout
chercheur d'emploi ou tout autochtones
qui désirent retourner aux études ou
même faire du réseautage sein on demande
soit autant premières nations et huit au
métier alors moi je pense que c'est
vraiment comme je disais ça regroupe
autant d'autres les services des
associations étudiantes autochtone des
organisations autochtones des employeurs
des centres de formation qui vont être
présents on veut également faire
connaître un programme qui s'appelle la
reconnaissance des role models
autochtone qui consiste à honorer des
finissants ah oui programme
d'employabilité de formation louis pour
leur faire justement les inciter à aller
plus loin dans leur carrière ou dans
leur cheminement
puis inciter les autres à retourner aux
études justement et puis le salon un peu
autochtone mamour est organisée avec des
autochtones
pis des organismes non autochtone qui
sont impliqués dans ce salon
voilà merci beaucoup de leur est venue
nous en parler merci evelyne d'être venu
témoigner merci beaucoup bon salon merci
à chasser une retrouverons la semaine
prochaine ainsi que matisse et merci
emilie d'être venu nous parler ont fait
d'eux un sujet incontournable d'un gros
sujet aujourd'hui emploi et diabète vous
merci à tous et à la semaine prochaine